hallo und herzlich willkommen hier aus
der maria theresien kaserne in wien zum
zwölften training fit aus dem lokal
gestern waren auch der schwerpunkt auf
der bauchmuskulatur heute setzt man den
umgekehrten punkt das heißt wir gehen
auch die rückenmuskulatur
das heißt ein rumpf krafttraining mit
schwerpunkt rückkehr
das ist gerade für die die für sitzen
und sie wenig bewegen und immer wieder
über rückenschmerzen klagen ein ganz
wichtiges training um hier die
muskulatur entlang der wirbelsäule zu
kräftigen und zu stärken wir das ist die
ecke das bin ich der beta und auf der
rechten seite der herbert wir führen
euch durch 30 minuten workout und wie
gesagt wir fahren ja ja gestern das
training gut überstanden heißt was gut
okay dann bewegen wir uns mal ganz
locker am stand das heißt mit stand live
beginnen wir wieder kreislauf in schwung
bringen
zweiter tag der woche draußen ist
korrekt vielleicht ist das büro an und
ganz aufgeheizt wenn ihr mitmacht oder
zu hause
das heißt wir müssen schauen dass man
den kreislauf in schwung bringen wenn
man die arme kreisen dazu vorwärts und
rückwärts kreisen
und nachdem wir heute den rücken
trainieren wären wir natürlich auch
schauen dass wir uns entlang der
wirbelsäule besonders gut aufwärmen okay
wenn man mich stehen nicht gewusst der
übung heute was ein was haben wir
gemacht schutz zum aufwärmen entlang der
wirbelsäule
ja genau machen wir gleich das heißt
oberkörper verdrehen auf die linken auf
die rechte seite könnt natürlich die
hände in die hüfte gm erkennt dass
mitnehmen schwungmasse mitnehmen
ihr kennt das entsprechend zur deckung
hoch geben vom boxen heraus varianten
gibt es viele
wichtig aus den erinnern was man mit dem
quasi wasserballett gemacht haben wie
die armhaltung der ausgeschaut hat ja
das heißt in die streckung mit beiden
armen in der rotation drinnen also in
unterschiedlichste varianten des
vertreters des oberkörpers damit drinnen
gehabt genau und ihr sucht sich eine aus
und macht sie einfach ok laufen wir
wieder
lockeres laufen am stand zwischendrin
einmal das knie hochheben zwischendrin
an fersen
die kanaan ferse nicht nur vorne gerade
von teil sondern versuchen seitlich das
knie hoch zu ziehen
ganz so gute übung im bereich der
wirbelsäule an mal ein bisschen schwung
zu kommen ist momentan vierfüßlerstand
genügend auf die bitten dass du es
entlang der matte max und habe du bitte
frontal
das heißt das sind vier füße stand
ausgangsposition neutralen über seile
das heißt natürlich ein schwung muskulär
abgesichert jetzt drückt sie einmal den
rücken nach oben durch das ist wie ein
katzenbuckel und jetzt in die andere
richtung durchdrücken wie ein
pferderücken sozusagen gerne also hoch
und runter katzenbuckel pferderücken 45
mal hin und her wechseln
einmal noch
kenner und wieder aufstehen und bewegen
uns wieder hempelmann haben wir schon
immer gemacht baumann gleich wieder mit
1 einmal hand einspringen so dass man
wirklich den kreislauf aktivieren und
entsprechend in schwung bringen
ok wieder ausloggen die beine oberkörper
in die vorhalte position und oberkörper
verdrehen wir können die hände wieder
mitnehmen
das heißt rotieren in der vorbeuge das
was die beweglichkeit hergibt bis zum
boden bis zum knie alle varianten
möglich
der gehört wechsel mal wieder in dem
boxer laufen was aktive boxer lauf
gleich als ausblick morgen haben wir als
inhalt das boxt ein boxtraining das
heißt morgen mit dabei sein er braucht
es keine zusätzlichen goldex einfach ihr
seid wieder mit dabei drin jetzt mit und
der wärme eine ein boxtraining halbe
stunde mit euch machen
also wie gesagt das ist bereits ein
ausblick auf morgen genau sagen
er hat ganz kurz zu dir eine rücken
übung zum aufwärmen
aber vielleicht doch mal was ihm sitzen
wir stehen haben wir genug macht zu
mobilisieren genau das heißt wir können
einfach genau haben wir bisher sind den
rückenmuskel hinein denen hinein bieten
aber locker als alles noch zum zum
aufwärmen ok und wieder aus der position
raus kommen immer wieder bäume dynamisch
wechseln
genau und noch mal reinziehen und wenn
man kleine position am boden sitzen dann
entsprechend die beine aufstellen und
knie links und rechts zum boden hinunter
genau mobilisieren auch entlang von der
wirbelsäule
genau jetzt kennen wir noch einmal die
beine ausstrecken leichter gerät stets
und die zehen hin und her drehen dass es
nach innen gibt nach außen kippen im
wechsel
und wie gesagt jetzt vorherige anspruch
und morgen haben wir wirklich einen
extrem erfolgreichen leistungssportler
bei uns den usa im backoffice in summe
hat er mehr will 130 boxkämpfen seiner
karriere gemacht ist top 16 der welt
also ist ein wirklicher top mann der
morgen dabei uns dabei ist okay dann
hätte ich sag' aufwärmen hammer
einigermaßen erledigt spart man mit dem
programm würde streiks dann aufgewärmt
fühlt sich gut an aber vergessen ja
rückenstrecke im bereich der
halswirbelsäule den nanometer ist ein
ganz wichtig das heißt blick wenden auf
die linke seite wieder wechsel auf die
rechte seite die übung kensy wir haben
auch jetzt noch dazu dass man da den
kompletten bereich der wirbelsäule auch
abgedeckt haben und nach oben und nach
unten die blick wendung und kopfneigung
natürlich sehr gut und nach links und
nach rechts gibt man den kopf und dann
macht man aber halbkreise vor der brust
sehr gut aber jetzt sieht jetzt geht's
los
erst die übung graue beine käme die
hammer schon zweimal trainiert das heißt
in der bauchlage den kopf ganz ruhig
ablegen auf den händen spannung aus dem
gesäß 10 lang beine strecken und
wechselweise das ganze dann anheben
wichtig dabei die beine sind gestreckt
kurze pausen richtet zu einem teil in 15
sekunden staat mehr los ich gebe euch
dann drei sekunden countdown und dann
fragt man nach fünf sekunden
bereitmachen 21 und zeit läuft wir
machen auch heute wieder 30 sekunden
belastung und 30 sekunden pause und die
von euch gekämpft das spiel bereits die
richtig gas geben wohin auch im bereich
der rückenmuskulatur können natürlich
selbstverständlich diese minute durch
arbeiten gibt es bereits für minute
durch arbeiten
wikis bereit hier zu hause auch das
heißt sehen sie kunden nur für die 30
sekunden variante und gesagt knapp die
halbzeit für die lange variante 30
sekunden sind vorbei herbert kurze pause
wir zeigen inzwischen die zweite übung
vor wir machen jetzt ein lastzug im knie
das heißt ihr knie zeigt auf dem boden
gibt es das gesäß nach hinten hinaus
genauso das ja schöne schräglage in dem
oberkörper hinein bekommt ohne nach
vorne umzukippen streckt die hände nach
oben und zieht wie wenn ihr in der
maschine drin sitzen würde es die
ellenbogen nach hinten unten und streckt
sie wieder nach oben diese bewegung
machen wir wichtig ist eine möglichst
gute schräglage 21 und arbeitszeit
position wechsele nikolaus nächste übung
wichtig dabei ist nur achtet darauf dass
nicht nach vorne umgibt und eine
möglichst gute schräglage im oberkörper
zu haben ganz in die rückenstrecke
richtig fordert
nach zehn sekunden
21 herbert kurze pause nicht gearbeitet
weiter nächsten übung macht man mal ein
bisschen was für die gesamte
rumpfmuskulatur das heißt den mount und
klein bei
die liegestütz ausgangsstellung ist
bekannt die übung kennt sie auch unser
dynamisches wechselweise anziehen linkes
und rechtes bein einer übung kann man
achtet darauf dass ja eine stolze brust
haben einen aufrechten geraden gerade
position im rücken
ok in fünf sekunden geht es wieder los
möglichkeit die position wechseln
drei zwei eins und los geht's auch in
der dynamik der bewegung achtet immer
darauf drückend bleibt gerade das becken
stabil und die beine arbeiten 15
sekunden durch und die minuten variante
ist beim outen klein war schon richtig
anstrengend weil da kommt das herz
kreislauf system so richtig in fahrt
da muss man halt die atmung dann wieder
mit die berücksichtigen 21 30 sekunden
zeit durch und die nächste übung die man
dann gleich auf die mountain klein war
drauf machen sind da ist wieder in der
bauchlage das nicht möglich ihn setzen
ja sondern eben die bauchlage hände
ausstrecken und ob das jetzt zwiebel
hacken holz hacken wie auch jemanden ist
es ganz egal wichtig ist dass der
hintern gespannt ist dass der oberkörper
leicht aufgehoben ist und die hände
dynamisch auf und ab arbeiten in
gestreckter position drei sekunden nicht
die position wechseln bereit machen und
zeit läuft gerne süßes sind am boden
hielt dann ist gespannt rücken sowieso
in der position wenn er abgehoben wird
noch 15 sekunden
genau die muskulatur arbeitet das ist
gut drei sekunden erste erster block ist
gleich vorbei und sah aus wie gearbeitet
darauf weiter genau signal gilt nicht
für die durcharbeiten nächste übung den
hit fastback beheben in der rückenlage
übungen auch schon eine altbekannte für
gesäßmuskulatur oberschenkelrückseite
und unteren rücken fersen sind am boden
becken drückt nach oben und geht wieder
nach unten
dynamisch rauf und runter und die unter
euch dieses schwer machen wohin strecken
ein bein dazu aus jänner in verlängerung
und wechsel 30 sekunden arbeitszeit
jetzt nach 15 sekunden sorge ich den
wechsel an dass sie entsprechend beide
seiten gleich mit drinnen haben beim
wechsel arbeit die fersen sind am boden
zehn schauen bitte nach oben ist
wirklich schön auf der ferse auf stein
und zwar genau dass man das gut erkennt
nicht bei dir bitte nur auf die ferse
gehen genauso pankow - schöner in die
zuarbeiten der muskulatur hinein 30
sekunden durch nicky halbzeit nächste
übung macht man ganz was anderes machen
wir mal die wadenmuskulatur der hat dann
aufstehen durchschütteln ausschnitt und
er stellt euch einfach in einem sicheren
guten start hin und geht aus der
normalen stand position in den zehn
stand und wieder runter wir es
schwieriger machen möchte kann natürlich
auch hier im einbein stand arbeiten
es ist doch nicht nur muskulär
anstrengend sondern auch fürs
gleichgewicht nicht uninteressant niki
kommt es geht los 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit wagen heben wenn es was zum
anhalten haben ist natürlich was zum
anhalten hier ja oder eine stiege
erschrocken was anna carina in die
position unter der gerade nano gehen
dann ist das möglich
und natürlich liebe mieterin jeder zu
hause sollte der fragen zu den übungen
haben gerne kommentiert des posters zum
video dazu die werden natürlich
selbstverständlich auch wieder
beantwortet 30 sekunden durch nächste
übung nach dem wahren leben macht man
das oberkörper aufrichten die übung
immer wieder dass wir wechseln wieder in
die bauchlage hinunter beide sind am
boden hinten gespannt das ist unsere
ausgangsposition
und jetzt da habe ich den oberkörper weg
vom boden nicht mit schwung nicht reißen
langsam mit der muskelkraft und in
sieben sekunden geht schon wieder los
nach 321 und zeit läuft auch hier kann
das schwerer machen indem man
beispielsweise die arme ausstreckt aber
eine minute oder 30 sekunden dort
wirklich durch zu arbeiten ist wie auch
immer die opposition ist in jedem fall
für den rückenstrecken gutes training
und das braucht man da will man hin noch
5 sekunden
und seit es aus die position keine wahl
gelassen herbert wir dann an der
nächsten variante in der bauchlage ihr
legt euch in den kopf kann es wieder
ablegen auf den händen da ist einmal
kurz entspannung auf dem bereich der
halswirbelsäule
jetzt haben wir 90 grad winkel im knie
und es zieht die oberschenkel nach oben
genau erkannt dass ein baldiger wechsel
machen
oder kennst von anfang an einig beide
gleichzeitig hochziehen gern auch
wichtig ist der winkel und dass sie
quasi mit den versen nach oben drückt
los gehts 30 sekunden arbeitszeit geht
schon los
wichtiger weiter atmen die spannung in
der muskulatur wahrnehmen gesäß und
rücken spüren wir ganz deutlich bei der
übung nach zehn sekunden
53 21 und zeit aus 30 sekunden sind
durch die nicht gemacht wie gesagt
fleißig weiter ihr zuhause auch ja eine
minute rückenmuskulatur volle belastung
jetzt in der übung
jetzt gehen wir in den vierfüßlerstand
das knie sind am boden arme sind am
boden und ihr könnt es da variieren
entweder streckt seine hand aus dem
wechsel zur anderen schatz dass der
oberkörper gerade bleibt oder er nimmt
diagonal das zweite bein noch mit dazu
genau das war ganz wichtig spannung aus
der hüfte heraus
ok zeit läuft übungs wechsel gerade
rückenstrecken kurze in der position
spannen und dann wieder positionen
wechseln sehr gut rücken bleibt gerade
rumpf bleibt gerade für das becken kopf
ist in der länge rung der wirbelsäule
nicht über strecken oder das team zur
brust bewegen ganz natürlich und normal
den kopf schossen 21 30 sekunden haben
wir durch arbeit kurz aus lockern die
knie position käme von der zweiten übung
dem auch mal jetzt noch einmal nur das
nächsten jetzt den land zu machen und
die hände bewegen sondern aus der
position schräger oberkörper genau jetzt
der linke rechte ellbogen verdrehen das
heißt arme zum boden herunter schauen
und auf der andere seite genau ok drei
sekunden position wechseln
aber es zeit läuft geht schon los schöne
schräglage dynamische drehung aus dem
oberkörper
daran wiederum nicht reißen in die
gelenks endposition sondern mit der
kraft arbeiten stolzer brust machen
oberkörper durchdrücken genau
und die letzte übung vom ersten
durchgang hammer und wir machen jetzt
den ganzen durchgang ein zweites mal und
dann ist das training hat schon wieder
abgeschlossen
30 sekunden arbeitszeit haben wir durch
nickel letztes meiner durchbeißen
spürst den rücken oder ist es doch okay
und zehn sekunden letzten zehn noch 321
und aus digital kurz aufstehen aus
laupheim muskulatur mal entlasten
jetzt machen wir ganz kurze pause den
korrekten kurz die spannung herausnehmen
ein schluck trinken und dann brauchen
wir einen zweiten durchgang und da geht
man noch einmal richtig gas eine minute
belastung rücken zehnmal hintereinander
mit unterschiedlichsten übungen und dann
sollte man mit den rücken so weit in
einem programm trainern haben dass er da
wirklich ein gutes training gemacht habt
ok ich würde vorschlagen nachdem er
nicht so viel zeit haben und alle
übungen durchgelegen wohin staaten in 30
sekunden wieder dann war minute pause
das muss eigentlich ganz wohl ausreichen
weil hochintensive körperliche belastung
also fürs herz kreislauf system war ja
jetzt nicht dabei und der rückenmuskel
der rückenstrecke ist gewohnt viel und
komplex zu arbeiten also dann können wir
gleich wieder mit vorrang erste position
grau keine zehn sekunden
rein militärisch jetzt angesagt über 30
sekunden kopf wie gesagt kein star
ablegen heißt visuelle ist entspannt
hinter nissan gespannt und knie sind
gestreckt
halbzeit
und das übungsprogramm ist natürlich
auch wieder für euch auf youtube kann
abgespeichert sie tatsächlich immer
wieder raus macht die übungen immer
wieder erzählen wer es richtig fit ok 30
sekunden durch kurze pause
meine herrn aber herren und damen
arbeiten beide weiter das findet
natürlich äußerst löblich beide sind
motiviert beide wo in den minuten jetzt
noch den zweiten durchgang als der
vollgas geben das muss arbeiten 15 sie
konnten ihr wisst die nächste übung den
lastzug wir haben sich bereits vor
gezeigt das heißt wir brauchen es nicht
nur um im detail erklären nur fünf
sekunden position wechseln 21
arbeitszeit läuft 30 sekunden lag
oberkörper schritt nach vor muskuläre
abgesichert die wirbelsäule haben wir
natürlich als ausgangslage und die arme
ziehen zurück richtig kräftig nach
hinten
zehn sekunden noch
30 sekunden arbeitszeit sind vorbei
bleibt drauf macht die 2 30 sekunden
weiter wenn auch kraft in der in den
rückenstrecken drinnen ist macht zweiter
nächste übung mountain klein bei sehr
kurze belastung danach für die
bauchmuskulatur und für sie als
kreislauf system das heißt der rücken
kann daher wieder ab diesel regenerieren
bei der nächsten übung also passt durch
macht super zehn sekunden noch 321
position wechseln liegestütz
ausgangsstellung und geht schon los
auch hinter liegestütz ausgangsstellung
grundsätzlich drücken muskulär gesichert
stabil gerade das heißt doch keine
experimente machen mit rund rücken und
so sondern einfach stabile position
oberkörper arme sind unter den schultern
und die knie bewegen sich dynamisch
foren zurück fünf sekunden dann hat 30
sekunden bereits durch 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit sind auch die zweiten 30
laufen
ich habe versucht einen eine stolze
brust zu lassen genau rückenstrecke
arbeiten das sieht man gut becken gerade
leistung so gut wie es geht
noch zehn sekunden noch 54 nächsten
übung zwiebel hacken 21 und los geht's
nicht vergessen hinter entspannen beine
am boden arme so gut wie es geht
gestreckt kopf ist in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule
das heißt der blick geht in die partie
hinein aber wenn man sich an besseren
ausblick vorstellen könnte wie die marke
vor einem jahr aber dass wir über die
halle saale wird es euch danken dass die
stabil und gerade gehalten wird variante
eins abgewinkelte arme variante 2
gestreckte arme variante 3 erkennt auch
die händler mal nach hinten strecken
waren die schultern schon kurz vorm
abbrechen 30 sekunden arbeitszeit ist
vorbei
voller spannung halten 20 sekunden noch
noch zehn weiter atmen kämpfen um die
position fünf sekunden nächste übung der
hit rast wechsel in die rückenlage nur
die fersen bitte am boden wieder
schwieriger ein bein ich sage euch nach
30 sekunden der wechsel zwischen
arbeitszeit geht wie die sie erst jetzt
zu schalten nicht sagen uns einmal kurz
die einbeinige variante bitte ein bein
strecken das könne bei jedem mal rauf
und runtergehen wechseln oder ihr könnt
das bei der halbzeit wechseln so wie es
für euch am besten passt drei sekunden
dann sind die 30 sekunden arbeitszeit
bereits vorbei auch die position der
arme kann euch das leben erleichtern
wenn ihr seitlich die arme am boden hat
sondern den boden hinein drückt wenn er
die arme in vorhalte gibt das heißt nach
oben streckt oder vor die brust gibt es
wird das ganze noch ein bisschen
intensiver weiter anteile der des
breiten rücken muskels nicht mithelfen
sondern nur der rückenstrecke fünf
sekunden dann ist bereits die hälfte des
zweiten durchgangs vorbei 21 auf einmal
wagen heben
jetzt kann darum von whistler entspannen
das haben wir mal kurz die beine
die waren mit dabei die arbeiten und den
rücken und den rückenstrecken kann man
mal etwas entlasten
in fünf sekunden satz bereits durch 30
sekunden haben erledigt zweiten 30
sekunden auch makler weiter der hd
variante wie es vorher schon erwähnt h
begrenzt sind ein wenig quasi euch nach
oben drücken
ihr könnt eure arbeit weitermachen so
dass die wahl gestellt belastet sind
zehn sekunden hat es nur noch 31
wechselt in die bauchlage oberkörper
aufrichten
da wieder zehenspitzen am boden hintern
angespannt oberkörper mit der
muskelkraft hochziehen nicht hochreißen
und kopf in verlängerung der wirbelsäule
30 sekunden das haben wir durch ja aber
doch nicht gesagt vor mit dabei 32
sekunden ihr zuhause bin ich mir sicher
ihr basta durch ihr macht das super mit
dabei sein mit trainieren dann wird man
stärker dann wird man besser 15 sekunden
nächste übung der vier füße
positionswechsel jetzt und diagonale
strecken arm und beine als variante nur
das bein strecken oder nur einen an
strecken natürlich genau so in ordnung
wäre noch genügend kraft im rumpf ort im
rücken hat der kann natürlich die
variante arm und bein
genauso wählen 30 sekunden sind wieder
durch
atmen 15 sekunden rom stabil halten bei
kapitel mit spannen dass das becken
nicht gibt noch 5 3 2 1 wechselte stand
oberkörper rotation schöne schräglage im
oberkörper und der elbe zieht richtung
boden und wechselt die seite das ist
eine dynamische belastung den wechsel
von rückenstrecke links rechts arbeiten
hin und her da auch stolzer brust kopf
in verlängerung der wirbelsäule und das
tempo wird sodass noch gut stabil knien
können 30 sekunden arbeitszeit durch die
letzten 20 sekunden
nach 10 das war bei zwei mal zehn
übungen eine minute oder 30 sekunden
belastung meisterschaft noch 211 30
sekunden beziehungsweise eine minute
arbeitszeit rumpfmuskulatur focus am
rücken danke danke herbert toll
mitgemacht doll vorgezeigt
rückentraining für heute ist
abgeschlossen noch einmal als
wiederholung für morgen morgen
boxtraining mit oman beckhoff ein
leistungssportler der top 16 der welt
ist und 130 kämpfe blues also mehr als
130 kämpfe in seiner karriere bereits
absolviert hat ein highlight ein
leckerbissen seitz morgen wieder mit
dabei
boxtraining morgen wir wünschen euch
heute noch einen schönen tag und sehen
uns morgen